didn't senior political analyst Brit
Hume is here tonight could even Brett
what do you make of all this today well
I think it was interesting that the the
leadership in the Democratic Party in
the Congress jumped on her with both
feet really and got her to issue what
she called an equivocal apology the
question remains now is whether any
actual further action will ensue you may
recall when Congressman Steve King of
Iowa a hardcore conservative who's been
accused of racial insensitivity and
worse was in court in a similar
situation he was stripped by the
Republican leadership of his committee
assignments this ms/ms Omar is now has a
seat on the House Foreign Affairs
Committee which is a coveted position as
we always say and so far no move to
strip her of any of our committee
assignments the other thing of course
Brett is that you know she did kind of
equivocate on the apology when she went
on to talk about how she was really
being critical of the influence of
lobbying lobbying of courses is by
another name for the petitioning of the
government for redress of grievances
which is protected by the First
Amendment so one wonders how far she'll
get with that yeah I mean a little bit
later in the show we have the story from
Virginia with the governor there and the
blackface scandal the lieutenant
governor with allegations of sexual
assault against him you have this
anti-semitism charge that all the things
Democrats are dealing with and trying to
deal with them quickly well this this is
this is one of the fruits of identity
politics when you pose as the party more
sensitive to various groups you're
vulnerable to charges it's you're not
sensitive enough and of course that's
what caught Ralph Northam the governor
of Virginia in its sights and of course
the meet to movement which is in a sense
of form of identity politics sensitivity
toward mistreatment of women you now
have the Lieutenant Governor in trouble
for that and and the situation in
Virginia looks like one where you
thought that the governor was gonna be
gone about ten days ago he looks like
he's there to stay and if he stays it's
hard to imagine that his the
the Attorney General who would be third
and line of succession
who's got the same problem the governor
has about a blackface incident whether
he could weather it why he would go and
of course Justin Fairfax who's accused
of rape and sexual assault is asking for
a full hearing which it's hard to
imagine he won't get that at least so it
looks like he's not going anywhere for a
while either so that situation Virginia
look we're looking a few days ago like
three minutes the three top Democrats in
the state might go down look like
they're gonna be there for a while Brett
to me anyway yeah your guests that
anything happens with representative
Omar well I think we'll have to wait and
see but I you know I kind of suspected
the Democratic leadership would like to
leave this where it is and treat her her
apology as as sufficient to let her
remain in her committee assignments and
it'll be interesting to see whether you
know they're further incidents of this
kind or further things that she has said
come to light something to watch for
Brett as always thank you